Була груша така, товста.
І на цій груші стояв вулик.
Я пам'ятаю, як старий дідок залазив на це дерево,
на цю борть, і збирав цей мед.
І дав мені невеличку... Його небагато було, пам'ятаю.
І дав спробувати цей смачний медок.
І я ним ласував.
То воно в мене в душі ще тоді зародилося,
що треба і собі так же ж.
Я так стараюся займатися,
щоб мене менше бачили сусіди,
бо це — село, тут почнуть одразу обговорювати,
що там такий дядько, знаєте...
Я завжди починаю із такого бігу.
А працює ж!
10 — 15 хвилин обов'язково мушу пострибати.
Кругові обертання обов'язково мушу
виконати зранку, для хребта.
Щоб добре було.
Кругові обертаня і впродовж дня
слід виконувати, під час праці.
Трішки слід повідтискатись.
Обов'язково!
Перегружати відтисканнями себе не потрібно.
І зранку, загалом.
Це так, коротенько.
Далі моя робота починається з того,
що потрібно вивести коника на пашу.
Стараюсь так, щоб якщо ти взявся
за цю роботу, то ти її повинен так зробити,
щоб від цього мати і до хати користь,
і щоб людям була користь. Я так вважаю.
Я так увесь час ходжу, босоніж,
до пізньої осені, допоки не похолодає.
Це корисно для здоров'я.
Доторкаюсь до землі і контакт іде.
У нас життя, в селі, неодноманітне.
Ми не працюємо так, як на заводах,
не виконуємо одну й ту ж роботу щодня.
У нас різноманіття: сьогодні до лісу,
завтра на городі, післязавтра ще щось.
Є різноманіття в житті.
Аж не віриться, що на Поліссі
таке може бути, правда?
Краще ніж на чорноземах!
Цієї пшениці мені достатньо на цілий рік.
Я на борошно собі її молотиму.
І мені не потрібно ні базарів, ні ринків, ні перекупників,
які возять комбікорми з піском та всякою тирсою.
У мене все екологічно чисте і своє.
Я вже зробив роботу і
знову веду її [коня] на випас.
А ввечері знову її забираю.
Якщо рахувати по роках,
то мені скоро вже виповниться 60 років.
То ходьба — це корисно для здоров'я,
ходити потрібно.
[ведуть розмову між собою
про добирання по певному маршруту]
[домовляються про місце зустрічі]
Жінка моя, ще школяркою була,
коли я в неї закохався.
Так ми вже 27 років живемо,
гарно живемо, маємо трьох дітей.
Рішення ми завжди приймаємо, порадившись вдвох.
Якщо чоловік завжди сам прийматиме усі рішення,
то він завжди буде думати, що він кращий.
До думки дружини дослухатися не буде.
І буде думати, що він сам все вирішує, а дружина ні.
А якщо вдвох вирішувати,
тоді і життя буде набагато краще.
Я займаюся бортництвом вже більше двадцяти років.
Займаюся, зокрема, для того, щоб зберегти лісову бджолу.
Хороша, хороша [гладить коня]. Гаразд, їж.
Наш охоронець [гладить собаку].
Ходім до тієї борті.
Там на землі борть стоїть.
Бджоли заселяються навесні,
коли починається роїння.
А також заселяються восени.
Також коли починається роїння.
Прилітають спочатку розвідники, вони ж і займають вулик.
Вони його очищають, охороняють,
і це вже буде їхній дім.
Димар треба розпалювати на пісочку.
Щоб не спричинити пожежі.
Бо підстилка у лісі зараз суха
і одразу може розпочатися пожежа.
Тому завжди потрібно старатися
розпалювати на пісочку.
Лісова бджола живе цілком у дикому стані,
що мільйони років тому, що зараз.
І вона є більш винослива,
більш пристосована до виживання.
Борті, як правило, старі.
Потрібно шукати старий ліс, стару колоду,
а тепер дуже важко знайти з діаметром таким.
Саме, щоб діаметром 60-70 сантиметрів
була, а то й товща.
Щоб усередині дупло було трішки більше.
Бо як мале, то мала сім’я.
Як більше, то більша сім’я.
Вона розростається, набирає велику міць.
І вони тоді добре наповнюють вулик медом.
От вони сюди і носять мед.
У лісі вони і зимують,
а я лише ходжу і спостерігаю за ними,
щоб ніхто нічого не пошкодив.
Влітку ці бджоли самі себе можуть захистити
від всіх шкідників, хвороб і людей.
От сюди вверх вони носять його [мед].
Вверх носять мед.
Ще до зими, до осені приносять мед сюди.
Ще не наносили.
Треба того побачити, де ж він там...
Мед, переважно, з лісових ягод.
З чорниці, з крушини носять.
Горобина також цвіте, з горобини.
Багон цвіте, і з ного носять.
Дуже багато лісових ягод.
Все знаходиться тут у дикому стані.
Десь до сорока у мене є бортів,
розкиданих в радіусі близько 20-и кілометрів.
Є в цю сторону, є в іншу сторону,
в сторону Білорусі,
є в Поліському заповіднику, усюди.
Щоб була площа живлення,
бо їх на одному місці не можна розмістити.
Треба, щоб пожива була,
щоб гектарів хоча б з 10 поживи було для бджіл.
Тоді вони будуть зносить мед.
Як не буде поживи, то бджоли
просто навіть не будуть займати вулик.
Діди, ті котрі займалися, старші діди,
вони вже небіжчики, а борті залишилися.
Впродовж двадцяти років я збирав ці борті.
Це ж не просто так вони оце...
Збирав для того, щоб зберегти оцю лісову бюджолу.
Це дуже важка праця.
Це дуже небезпечна робота,
бо ти постійно працюєш на висоті.
Це постійно потрібно кудись вилазити.
А ще буває, що я з'єдную дві драбини,
і залажу на висоту 8 метрів.
А через що на таку висоту?
Бо борті знаходяться далеко в лісі, за 20 кілометрів.
А я там раз в рік буваю, хтозна що там
може статися, різне може трапитись.
А якщо там є мед, то ж мені потрібно
його зібрати, а за нього треба братися руками.
То ще й бджоли кусають.
Бачите, як одразу нападають.
[каже до дружини] Відійди.
Оце є такі труднощі.
Так воно не легко дається.
Я дуже хотів меду, дуже любив мед.
Але ж так хотів меду...
З чого я почав — як я поставив борть,
то мене вкусила бджола.
Як кусали мене чи в лице, чи за шию,
то голова у мене опухала.
І очі...Все лице опухало.
Очі такі вузенькі ставали.
Отака алергія була.
Я дуже боявся, страх як боявся.
Але ж меду дуже хотів!
Бувайте і до зустрічі!
[кличе дружину] Людо!
Ходи сюди, зробимо собі фотографію.
Ходи сюди, нам робитимуть
фотографію, будеш в інтернеті!
Ходи коло Муніка, треба щоб вона була.
Що?
Не прийдеш?
Чого ти? Ходи сюди!
Та вона вже пішла ягоди шукати!
У даний час бортників стало більше.
Порівняно десь...Якщо у відсотках,
то на 50% більше, ніж раніше.
Я вважаю, що це пов'язано із зацікавленістю
молоді, щоб це ремесло не зникло.
У нас річка тече — Уборть,
і село поруч – Перга.
Коли бджоли зносять пилок,
вони переробляють його на  пергу.
Перга — це бджолиний хліб.
Вони ж, навесні, харчуються пергою
і виводять молоде потомство.
То в нас навіть так села
називаються — село Перга.
Річка Уборть.
Колись навесні великий
паводок був і почало вимивать,
і такі тисячолітні дуби повимивало,
тоді ж ми знайшли і борті, які повимивало.
То я можу сказати, що вони
тут були з давніх давен.
Оце — стара лійка.
Колись, у давнину, люди з соняхів олію лили.
І таке пристосування прижилося і до меду.
Отже, ставиться сюди, під низ, кастрюля, отак.
Отак воно робиться.
— Оцей мед ставиться сюди.
— І вставляється.
— А цей, оцей, вставляється сюди.
— Просто лляний мішечок робиться.
Лляний мішечок заливаємо, розігріваємо.
Щоб мед потрапляв на решето і сюди витікав.
Всередину вставляється мішечок.
А потім, збоку, забиваємо клини.
І вони віджимають цей мед.
Так і так.
А тепер — забиваю.
І мед вже стікає туди, у каструлю.
Мед увесь витікає, а віск — залишається.
А віск ми перетоплюємо і здаємо.
Це ще дідівський метод.
Вона [лійка] до мене потрапила від нашого
найголовнішого і найстаршого пасічника.
Він дуже, дуже...
Ошумко Степан такий в нас був, пасічник.
Той цій лійниці вже також буде років близько 50.
Але вже перед смертю від мені її передав.
Каже: «Тримай, Толя, займайся
і продовжуй свої традиції».
Та й я вже, колись доживу до своїх років
і не зможу цим займатись, буду передавати.
І так воно й піде дальше.
Так ми й живемо. Це така система.
От я цими бортями займаюся
і мені це цікаво, дає якийсь поштовх життю.
А так йдеш по лісу, бачиш свою борть
і бджоли мед носять.
І так стає добре, ти задоволений.
І йдеш далі.
Але як бачиш пусту сосну, то це звісно нецікаво.
Думали, що вже вимерла та лісова бджола,
а ні, ми не дамо їй тут вимерти.
Вона в нас, навпаки, буде дедалі
більше оживати, так би мовити.